hi my name is even Bruckner and I'm from
the Regional Hospital monton Craddock
kada and today I will talk about global
penetration and G of genomic like
techniques into plank of Diagnostics I'm
working in a clinical environment hmm
and in the history I was doing a lot of
genomics work developing dna-based
agnostics and I'm still doing that with
pleasure but I'm realizing more and more
that need for the fast essays is
critical and considering new generation
of sequencing techniques I will just try
to focus on a technological bottlenecks
which are preventing as used and
immediately and turn some of the hints
how to resolve them but first let's go
to the applicability so there are cases
which are of medical emergency and those
to which a big especially are many
kitties and sepsis and as you see there
unfortunately inverse relation time
before you get your antibiotic where
every hour counts and the survival rate
are inversely proportional after 36
hours you're sort of cooked so in other
words if you don't get a light drug
which is based on the right technologies
it's very very bad ten doctor make us
mistake of course especially because the
signs of negatives are easily mistaken
by flow and I just pick one example from
internet which recently if I find in
april six person came to the hospital
doctor without of course and speed
show thought it's sort of pneumonia said
some come back and two days later the
guy came back and his dad from bacterial
meningitis of course signed developed
later so I'm not saying doctor missed
something it's simply tough to make
right decision in the right moment let's
say that you get it and it's recognized
what are the chances that she will
survive well between 1775 percent so
unfortunately 30-34 one-third almost
died out of it and even if you survive
especially among pediatric patients were
it's mostly common there are chances
that they will be reversible brain
damage hearing problems and so on it's
worse but with the bacterial then with
then with while mitigated however the
fast Diagnostics again will help
immediately as you know for one of many
get is the most frequent is enterovirus
you do not do much with that but with
campuses it will do a lot and you can
refocus the whole therapy baseman right
diagnosis and shoot at the Gloria high
dosage and say the person could of
course athlon 64 it's viral here is a
recent recent histogram showing what's
happening with results so once you are
admitted to the emergency you see picea
could be done mm faster than six hours
but on average in this institution was
done in six hours you're let's say that
you have making it intercepts it is your
bugs load is growing so only a few hours
you will be eligible to be seen by Gram
stain it's a sensitivity problem and
after Gram stain when they see something
they will make a culture they will try
to identify bugs and they will culture
it so it take up to maximum 30 something
worse until identification is done and
refocusing of therapy could start and
meantime the culture is growing now over
these elastic colony and drug-resistant
profile will be discovered so the final
result could be between 36 and hundred
and something hours and comparing to the
first six hours where you can get pc
result with identification the hint of
how you refocus gariepy that's really
the ways that we are not doing faster
Diagnostics when I said pcr I just want
to stress that doesn't need to be P
shallots any page nucleic acid-based
diagnostics and most level here targets
next-generation sequencing we hear you
we were trying to use it in man get it
we like CG in any case in Canada and in
this hospital we use it further I says
it's an elegant multiplex Isaac however
for many kitties was showing not enough
sensitivity because as you know
multiplexing in spite of its so elegant
and done in one tube sacrifice of
sensitivities and here in a case of
meningitis except she's every molecule
counts there are other assets there is a
rush steps as I say there are other
essays which are presently very
interesting but i'm afraid that
multiplexing with such biological fluid
like maybe it is which is cerebral
spinal or serum case of sepsis we really
need a single molecule resolution so
what is done now and what was done
before is more or less same detection
diagnosis is still relying on
traditional culturing and that's in a
way good because this here could be
negative or any any detection method
which is fast could be negative and you
really want to have this back grown and
find out resistant pattern as we saw the
mortality rate is so high you cannot
miss this opportunity whoever you are
also wear that as soon as the patient is
suspected on many get interceptions that
he will receive spectrum of antibiotics
wide range of idiot antibiotics and that
will somehow influence also the culture
is out so you might after all those 36
and hundred and something hours not even
know what was there and hopefully
patient will survive so I found that
from a scientific point to feel very
very frustrating and there are two
reasons why I think absolutely nucleic
acid affection early in the in the
process should be nucleic acid detection
should be introduced first empirical
therapy could be switched very fast to
the specific therapy so as soon as
possible which if you are targeting
viruses antifungal antibacterial case
you can focus on one of those agents and
then if you buy identity of bug know
roughly how they are responding you can
you can refocus on to antibiotics so
obviously information about the pathogen
and eventually resistant profile will be
more more than welcomed however you will
keep for a while running culture as a
backup in a case that of course pcr was
or amplification was negative though it
is another example that thirty percent
of certifications die which makes
quarter million people and for the
surfaces same as for me it is the
recommendation ours yes you will get a
wide broad spectrum antibiotic but then
it will be focused and targeted therapy
will be anyway preferred and again come
here i'm trying to mention that in a
number of cases the culture will be a
dl- so you can not learn anything from
the so-called or your personal
experience with all those patients which
is again i said
shaking so how to address this how to
put some reason how to put some logic
behind the fact that somebody had sepsis
and suddenly doctor I don't know two
weeks he feels fine and culture was
negative we have to apply sequence
independent methods and amplify whatever
is present in those tariffs Lloyd's when
I said style fluid suppose it was their
voice this is again terrible spoon flats
liquid which should be without anything
and plasmid sell the sterile of course
there will be for sure degraded host DNA
and some cells in all those approaches
you will apply a sort of random priming
degenerative oligonucleotides six verse
nightmares with all set of combinations
of nucleotides and try to shoot and
amplify whatever you have in in the
sample and after that you will put
everything on the downstream platform
whatever it is so what are really
technological problems what's this
bottleneck preventing us to apply
next-generation sequencing it
immediately and emergency well
unfortunately detection of small
quantities of low molecular nucleic
acids and unfortunately viruses are as
we know low molecular it could be RNA
DNA bugs are about few ten thousands in
a number of cases detection small
quantity with a little so small in a
sense of morality small number of
molecules plus they are short it's very
fruitless it's frustrating the other
thing is contamination which one's DNA
which could be sorta frustrating in a
process of filtration the signal which
is important however as I said in
sterile fluids that's not so important
so what's really happening here with
random degenerative nucleotides which
used of the vacation is self priming
which is in a number of cases
sort of killing reaction during the
during the preparation of this talk I
realized these people are thinking in a
context of what's producing what's
making my negative ctrl+ after I perform
whole genome amplification so I know
this whole simplifications 329 days or
it's a pcr-based in all those cases
there are chances that the negative
control will be positive and some of
those groups believe that you'll be
radiation of material forming teamer of
demons will help I will doubt personally
some think that it's best to really
isolate single molecule or separate
somehow physically for another one and
continued communication with those
however even in those cases
unfortunately you need minimum hundred
copies in this case paper on the screen
it's West Nile virus which is again main
gate this case and in reality instead of
Erskine fluids as we know from our for
example campus cases you can end up with
really something between 1 and 10 200
molecules because simply some of those
bugs are not leaking enough into
cerebral spinal fluid so you have to be
sensitive that's for sure now we are
going to another step deeper we are
saying that pathogens could be of course
linear DNA after we isolate let's say 40
minutes you got the sample you isolate
your sample nucleic acids and you have
either DNA which is linear you have RNA
virus or you can sell for DNA at the
beginning historically looking people
like circular DNA because it was wrong
to rolling certification so it was sort
of dojang given to read circularize even
linear DNA the problem with check for
DNA is the Watson click there
complementary strands tend to tear each
other in reality if you don't apply our
circularization step with legates it's
hardly will get super coil DNA so that
that's more resin realistic any as I
said competition with primers which you
want or specific primers will sort of be
compromised because of the self
annealing of two complementary strengths
so the most common is linear DNA or RNA
so I will I will now go into the 329
just because we pick this model system
as the most promising system yes it has
only single denaturation step comparing
to some pcr-based techniques where there
is a multiple cycles and because there
is no thermal label polymerase and it's
very interesting this 329 polymerase
which was few the cards discovered by
margaretta salas and then revitalized
with a molecular stage in testing
company and then with a theory of nice
people down on the human DNA shown that
there is no bias that somebody can
really use it to amplify whole genome
DNA of humans and high mile away DNA and
however the whole protocol has to be
significantly adopted in order to be
applied to small genomes and there are
also multiple generation steps
polymerase is like BST one recently
right that bsd one could be used even
like tax sort of where there is a small
variation between 60 and 70 degrees and
those two methods are unfortunately much
more prone to bias and what dr. fistic
safi 29 enzyme which is the main
component of whole genome amplification
kids produced by kyochon or
General Electric sitting by them
metrocenter the enzyme everybody selling
the enzyme well first it strong
participated meaning that as an can go
up to 80 kb that's very very important
detail and we tend to forget that
actually if we take this as fact it will
open the door for 44 other modifications
in our protocols also we should be aware
that because the civilization is one
step in this case efficiency of
liberalization is sort of critical of
those starting vege- primers of six
months so whatever happen it will happen
to be the first step of the iteration
and after that there is still binding of
six months to the display strand but it
will be just how to say local not sure
the local no clothes amplification
around the local first events and it
will be sort of restricted so what will
happen if look like I said short as we
know especially I could lower than 2,000
baby baby base pairs and personal
experience lower than few 10,000 of base
pairs so it's there is a significant
restriction for small genomes and to go
around all this is to apply legation
step and that was shown in battalions by
repeat a few times so whenever you have
degraded DNA I'm just shoot like is
convert it into the big DNA large
molecular weight DNA and because of this
strong facility your feet 29 now can
show which can really feel on molecules
that works but it doesn't work when the
number of copies is close two hundred or
even less well and that's exactly the
case where we needed meningitis
insectia's
I just remind you to them to the somatic
presentation present on lincoln electric
site it's free 29 reacting with random
hexamers who's the ntp push your input
DNA so it lets you know even if you
don't have input DNA unfortunately
reaction can be positive however if you
have input DNA what is happening is
detected below there is a annealing
elongation and then lots of displacement
noon-6 mature coming and DNA is
amplified to a few 10 power 4 10 power 5
times and now back to the self priming
what's happening when there is no DNA
outside added or it's in very small
quantities well because the
concentration four nucleotides sorry not
because it's all gonna play at random 6
verse hexamers is very high they will
tend to form Watson quick sort of
pairing at the three prime end anneal
elongate and produce the product which
bizarre enough can become up to 20 kb's
again 20 carries out of six nurse six or
eight fantastic and two I heard that the
companies are going the rounds of this
in a way that they're changing position
of six verse so they will put pyrimidine
only 6 verse or pouring like GA rich 6
verse and that works relatively good
you're you're no DNA control is much
much less Browns almost invisible but
limits of detection are still remaining
similar in other words small number of
molecules especially their shorts you
cannot still amplified so yes changing
composition was applied but did not
solve totally the problem and introduce
additional bias which was recorded in
bed by technique
two years ago sickness bias we what we
are doing we were even seven years
before we decided to put c3 linker at
the fibrin region and IDT company knows
very well how to do it and they knows
are as a customer so our no DNA control
is really no product control so once you
do your VGA you know there is nothing
there well it didn't work and you have
to find out why I didn't work you will
not enter into the downstream process
and try figure out is my pc are not
working the zone because it will be
clear message that there was no
amplification and we are still using
this protocol which is quite simple back
to legation obviously whatever we do
even with you block self-priming it's
not totally helping in a sense of
sensitivity although we were hoping that
blocking self-priming will open door for
amplifying your extra target DNA and
because at some point we were thinking
there is a competition between those two
processes maybe there is a competition
but obviously it's not enough to explain
why there is no shift in limits of
detection even with when you block some
priming and I think the key is that 329
is high process of enzyme it can go back
to eight eighty thousand eight pairs and
that if DNA is short that simply it's
not helping and there is no enough big
number of events of binding of six nurse
and elongation switch will produce high
molecular weight DNA so that's why i
like is works in a number of cases
however like it cannot work if
concentrations are long as well small
simply a cage a ligase
constant association is in low
micromolar or I know normal range and we
are talking about ten hundred molecules
this is autumn all arranged so you don't
have enough substrate to get to get the
product of course when you have a DNA of
which is degraded in a high
concentration to work so what's the way
out what we try to do is and we did it
is a Legation of the six whatever is
intended target DNA which one top if I
would come a polymer at that time
pharmacia now general electric's was
selling Pauly da dat so we looked into
characteristics is about 8 kb eight
thousand base pairs on average along the
DNA we were sure it is double-stranded
we process with the enzyme to make it
double stranded with the button and and
we simply like it to our target DNA and
we make the duration curves we do the
same thing instead of homo polymer with
a human DNA and we reach 10 10 molecules
sensitivity so I like a sure and it's
always making these illusions i hope to
this protocol which I'm telling you is
not illusion and the example they will
continue with the steps and the tall
together we can push genomics into the
clinics faster because this is really
the bottleneck how to how to sequence
those small number of molecules before
sequencing how to amplify that yeah so
artificial homo polymer poly dadt about
8,000 nucleotides has to be in a huge
accession honestly speaking i forgot
what few tricks as its analytical
chemistry 2005 paper and
it's it simply to understand the magic
is the probability of Legation is now
increased and with a lot of substrate
you're pushing even the enzyme with
allocated toward product and with our
model systems plasmid puc 18 linearized
bunt ended so it was definitely and it's
you know in a small number of copies
between zero and thousand and we did all
testing and we get really encouraging
results however I must admit that the
process is a little bit how to say
requires molecular biology and
biochemistry nucleic acid because you
need to phosphorylate your how to say
your your homo polymer or waxed DNA
angel you need to rise in a kinase you
need to fill in if there with
restriction enzymes if there is a
stagger between strands you need to fill
in with t4 Paul polymerase and then you
are applying t4 legation but everything
in a mixture could work very very
elegantly so back to the magic if it's
just efficacy of liberalization of six
nurse to high molecular DNA is now
increased because hi priscilla t of 329
is allowing all those long molecules to
get amplified in other words if you
imagine in your head and it was it was I
must admit at some point it was control
logic abut if you imagine that there is
a small segment surrounded by
homopolymer on the left and right side
and event of utilization happened far
away hundred thousand base pairs far
away because of the purchase inity the
train was still pass through your target
DNA
you will get what you want in spite it
is a very low number of molecules and
that makes sense because we all know
that with a long single cell DNA we can
do some job human of course but we
cannot do the same with a single bug and
that was the message of my presentation
I will check questions and so far I
don't see questions so I will thank you
very much for attention and I hope that
among some of us there will be a
curiosity to repeat there will be some
courage to repeat and push genomics
techniques more close to the emergency
rooms where they really deserve to be
considering the input they could have
that will not only open jobs and it will
help doctors and that will help patients
really who need fast diagnosis in those
two fatal cases again thank you very
much and bye